these are the three craziest things that
happened at skankfest starting off with
Joe D Roa getting frisky with a
transgender woman on night one that's
got to be a weird walk to know you're
going to to a bathroom to know you're
going to jerk off a trans person what
are you thinking about in that
walkies that is almost unbelievable but
speaking of Happy Endings Brian Callen
and Brandon sha showed up to skankfest
to bury the hatchet with the Legion of
skanks he's so much bigger than you guys
realize holy sh so much easier to talk
sh on the internet between the nightly
naked roast battle or the blind
kickboxing at Ellis Mania skang Fest is
full of wild moments but number three
had to be column Terrell's midnight
circus show where everyone was
encouraged to take psychedelics before
the chaos ensued I saw Ari take
someone's glasses and put them on his
dick and then put it back on the guy's
face that was AR's trick yeah AR came up
and told a story that was during the
show yeah out